[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: The things, in the Internet of Things,
potentially include everything - living things,
and very ordinary things, and very big things.
However, it is actually the sensors in things that collect information,
and it is the actuators that might receive instructions from the internet
to make the things act...
hence, the IoT's ability to feel and act.
Confused?
Well, let's look at an example.
Imagine a sprinkler system.
Think big.
Think outside yourself.
Think of one on a huge farm, where an intelligent watering system can
save water and increase profits.
Yes, that's better.
So, this smart sprinkler system--
EVERYMAN: Hmm.
SPEAKER 1: It is smart, yes, if you'll let me go on.
There's a moisture sensor in the soil, and it sends information
about moisture levels, which is collated together with online weather forecasts.
The system decides if it needs to water, and for how long,
and sends that command to the sprinkler.
The sensor is the moisture detector.
And the actuator is the valve and solenoid
that start and stop water flow.
And they both connect to the internet to control the sprinkler.
So the system is smart; sensing, thinking, and acting,
without any person being involved.